ich
muss statt
mama was dann kam meine lieben freunde
meine mutter befindet sich gerade hinter
der kamera am
fuß
ich habe euch auf instagram auf jeden
fall gefragt ob wir einige fragen an
mich hart und die werde ich euch jetzt
vorlesen allerdings mit meiner mutter
diese fragen zuerst beantworten
heute schon die erste frage wieso ist
deine nase so lang
wie geht's dir ist so zeit
kannst du auch lustige videos drehen
was würdest du tun wenn du ein alpaka
werd
ich deutsche wehrt euch alle anspruch
hast du geplant einen gaming kanal auf
zu machen
habe ich nicht ich habe meine hauptkanal
wo wir uns gerade befinden wo ich alles
mögliche klage auf gaming
ich finde den zu gern zeigen wie du da
sind
wo wir befinden uns gerade im zimmer
meiner schwester weil meine eltern
meinen schreibtisch einfach verkauft
haben
ihr habt sogar verschenkt was ist dein
größter wunsch
ich werde selbst auf dem mond gar keinen
bock wenn ich kostenlos zum mond fliegen
würde ob sprachenlernen merge oder so in
planung aber
weiß auch schon was
ich weiß ja selber nicht so richtig
dass das was ist das gegenteil von anja
eigentlich ausleihen
ist zählen die deine beste freundin und
ich habe ich meine besten freunde
wann kommt minecraft mit luca aber
zackig
muss ja auch wiesn-fans die sache mit
mannschaften luca ist dass wir da was
klein ist leider passiert es in der welt
aber wir die tage in info video zukommen
luca wie heißt dein online schon
bist du dumm
was magst du mehr pipi oder kaka machen
schwierig
was mag ich mir
ich hab auch kaka machen noch mehr spaß
weil man sich so oft macht wie machen
ist so normal es
auch die die frage
wo würdest du hinziehen wenn du die
freie wahl hätte
ich glaube nicht mehr war früher mein
ziel ich glaub ich würde sogar
de ich will vorerst mal in köln bleiben
glaube ich aber
auf dauer vielleicht keine ahnung ich
fühle mich ganz wohl hier über ein zitat
oder saß der die gänsehaut gibt
vielleicht luca minister punkte was ist
jetzt mit deiner wohnung in hamburg wenn
wir nur noch in köln bis
hat uns wir sind der freunde da
wird überwacht
so aktuell pendelt ich selber noch so
ein bisschen aber ab märz mit meine
wohnung in köln umgebaut da bin ich nur
in hamburg und danach werde ich dann mal
gucken wahrscheinlich wieder in köln
wohnen rammbock vermieten die frage
hätte ich gern mal von dir vorgelesen
fach song hat was das bedeuten könnte
nicht ganz
htm es ja doch table song at the moment
also zurzeit dann mein absoluter
lieblingssong aktuell fast denkst du ist
mein aktueller lieblingssong von
baby
durch monster.com und so zum boxen warum
heißt du nicht mehr konkret ab
laser lokals genauso dann
doch konkret zehn buchstaben und laser
cut 9
ja aber es hat auch mit minecraft zu tun
gehabt als ich mich um genannt habe habe
ich fast keine minecraft mehr gemacht
und dachte ich komm kraft dann auch
keinen sinn nämlich laser luca genauso
wie auf ins reich mehr reallife content
gemacht habe
das gar nicht mehr so spannend das video
können fischer eigentlich durst haben
stimmt wenn dir eine frage beantwortet
werden könnte welche würdest du nehmen
stimmt
darüber will ich gar nicht nachdenken
wenn du die frage nehmen würdest dann
würde ich nehmen was ist das größte
geheimnis was vor der menschheit bewahrt
wird von irgendwie
beiden und putin und so
was das größte geheimnis der menschheit
was meisten menschen gar nicht wissen
was
für die recht dunkel
wenn mein gesicht nicht mehr so gut
würdest du auch mal andere berufe
kennenlernen
die aber primär als praktiker
oderzeitung austeilen unserem quatsch
also architektur das sollte immer noch
bock drauf
oder musiker ich kann er relativ gut
sehen
[Musik]
wie viel verdienst du im monat
ach sonnig ist das hier machst du mal
eine wohnungstür
[Musik]
ich weiß auch nicht was jetzt genau ist
aber vielleicht irgendwann mal wo siehst
du dich in fünf jahren
genau hier über sagen uns immer videos
aufnehmen weil mein schreibtisch aber
noch nicht wieder draußen
beziehungs muss
ehrlichkeit
[Musik]
letzte fragen wir mal ist mies wie suppe
doch
dann bist du von mir schon
ab jetzt so buchstaben nudeln in seiner
brüder schwimmen oder ob meine keks
kellogg's im milch schwimmen ist also
man löffelt beides genau genommen ist
eine suppe
weißt du eigentlich warum sand sand
heißt
weil zwischen see und land liegt
und weiß warum stau stau stau
kommt von stehende autos
glaube schon schon gewesen
danke
möchtest du noch irgendwas
abschließendes daran uns hat die letzte
frage
perfekt